bash a command language interpreter for
interacting with a computer from the
command line it's also called a shell
because it surrounds the operating
system kernel to hide its intricate
details while allowing you the
programmer to do important stuff like
access data and write files by typing
simple commands this was a revolutionary
concept when it was developed in the
early 70s back when programmers were
still using punch cards the shell
concept evolved over the years with the
bourne shell being the most popular
version that is until 1989 when the
born-again shell or bash came about when
you open up the terminal on a unix
machine like mac os and most linux
distros the default shell is usually
bash it provides a prompt where you can
type a command which will then be
interpreted by the shell and executed on
the operating system to find out if
you're running bash type in which dollar
sign shell from the command line it's
like any other application that lives in
the binaries directory but bash is also
a programming language that allows us to
write scripts which means anything we
type manually into the command line can
be automated with code when you first
launch the shell it actually runs a
startup script that's defined in the
bash profile or bashrc file on your
system this allows you to customize the
behavior and appearance of the shell
whenever you start a new session you can
add your own custom bash scripts to any
project by creating a file that ends in
dot sh for no file extension at all the
first line in that file should always be
a shebang followed by the path to the
application that should run it below
that we can start writing commands like
echo to print something and they'll be
interpreted line by line to create a
variable type a name in all caps
followed by the equal sign then
reference it later in the script using a
dollar sign in front of the name now to
execute the script simply type the file
name into the shell that was easy but
what if we want to pass in some
arguments when we run the script
positional arguments will automatically
be assigned variable names of 1 2 3 and
so on now in other cases you may need
additional user input in the middle of a
script you can create loops in bash like
a do while loop here that will prompt
the user to continue the script on a yes
answer or exit on a no answer from there
we can implement conditional logic with
an if statement which will test if the
value on the left side is less than the
value on the right side if true then run
this command otherwise run the else
command another cool feature is that if
you have multiple long running processes
you can run them in parallel in the
background by adding an ampersand after
the command this has been bash the
born-again shell in 100 seconds if you
want to see more short videos like this
make sure to hit the like button and
subscribe thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one